vedi tutte queste cose una volta qui era
tutta campagna
[Musica]
non dia nessuno che li ho dati quando
ero giovane io che non solo televisore
per tutto il paese
adesso ce ne sono almeno tre o quattro
per ogni caso leandri questo coso pronto
pronto non ti sento cosa hai detto ha
chiamato la mamma non l'ho capito ha
chiamato la mamma colta bimbo da storico
che di qua non ci sento divertiti finché
sei giovane ascolta la nonna lella di
una volta era bella musica quella di
adesso come farà il rumor semo sentiremo
che porterà come non hai mangiato a
nonna intessendo piuttosto il proprio i
fossi per il lungo alla tua età io già
mi cucivo a macchina a tutti i vestiti
altro che fashion week quella rara moda
perché adesso sono anziano ma quando ero
giovane
quante ne ho fatto erano tutte
innamorate di me ma se non hai mangiato
niente brand in è ancora un po caro mio
quando c'era il duce bei tempi giovane
con la testa rover 60 e oltre anno lo
pago andar a giava
secondo me sei troppo magra fatelo di
voi giovani d'oggi non avete rispetto
per gli anziani nel conto sorpreso la
pastiglia giovanna ma tu non sai chi è
morto a me la pastiglia l'ho presa
secondo me sei troppo bianca
adesso di voto a ma devi portarti dal
dottore perché secondo me se anche un po
anemica devo andare a prendere la
pastiglia cala creta mi facevo 400
chilometri in bicicletta solo per andare
a trovare tua nonna ma che non è al
ginocchio domani o piove o nevica peso
guarda che bella sciarpata fatto olona
questa col freddo resta ora che serve
che cos'è la spa fare qua e cosa cosa
serve il nonno per contattare i miei
amici ma quando io avevo la tua età e se
volevo dire una cosa un mio amico andavo
a casa sua
non so se te l'ho detto ma io facevo 400
chilometri tutti i giorni in bicicletta
per andare a trovare sai chi non prova
che scagiona a telefono spetta come
funziona qua pronto non presento ma chi
è meglio un po se riesci a parlarcene
hanno troppi reclame si può vedere al
telegiornale in santa pace la pubblicità
ai miei tempi
ai miei tempi con duemila lire andavamo
al cinema è una volta usciti c
compravamo pure al gelato stato il bagno
arrivo subito è aspettare qua alla tua
età io già l'ho sposata con quattro
figli nonna ma poi il figlio unico
questa per me più the rip la nonna
sentite un po visto che mai state
parecchio simpatici e se questo video
arriverà 70.000 vi piace gireremo la
seconda parte c'è lo volete vedere
mettete mi piace il fiere e al canale
e attivate la campanella sennò le
notifiche comparivano e non dimenticate
di seguirmi su tutti gli altri soci che
su instagram pitt e facebook mi
raccomando eh ma mbolhì mando un bacio e
coppa d'oro
[Musica]